beliefs and information that supports
our prior beliefs also increases the
activity of these reward systems so the
more I see stuff that verifies what I
already think or feel that they are bad
and they are good or that we are good
and they are bad the more dopamine and
adrenaline is released into my system it
actually changes the way I view the
world it means that I'm going to see
certain things and not see others and
this also relates to the auditory system
I'm going to hear certain things and not
hear others the things that verify my
beliefs are I'm going to feel rewarded
for the things that are counter to my
beliefs not going to be it's rewarded
for so we have all these barricades to
empathy and to really listening and to
really hearing what the other side is
trying to say and we have all these
support networks in our body and our
brain which are building a bigger and
bigger divide so the question is what's
the boat that's going to get us across
that divide I fundamentally believe that
the boat that's going to get us to the
other side is our ability to control our
internal state